problema número 207 si es igual a 4 p
donde p es un número primo mayor a 2
cuantos divisores pares positivos hay nn
incluyendo lo que damos que n es igual a
4 p
y esta p es mayor a 2 y es un número
primo buenos puntos divisores 6 bueno va
a estar el 4 porque lo estoy
multiplicando por cuatro si está el 4
también va a estar el 2 obviamente va a
estar p que es un número primo y si es
primo va a ser divisible entre sí mismo
y la unidad nada más y por supuesto
nuestro factor 1 que esté siempre va a
estar en todas partes que necesitemos
encontrar factores estos son todos los
divisores que lo que nos preguntamos
cuántos de estos solamente los positivos
pares bueno uno no es paz este no es paz
de no estar porque es número primo y
como es mayor que 2 ningún número primo
va a ser divisible entre 2 excepto 2 por
lo que sólo nos quedan 4 y 2 que son 12
divisores pares positivos y es nuestra
opción a veamos el siguiente problema
número 208 ese es un conjunto que
contiene 9 números diferentes y te
un conjunto de ocho números diferentes
que son parte de ese cuál de las
siguientes afirmaciones no puede ser
verdadera la primera es la media de ese
es la media de te imaginemos que ese
tiene estos números dos tres cuatro
cinco seis siete y ocho nueve y me faltó
el 1 cuál es su media si promediamos 9 y
1 nos va a dar 5 si promediamos 8 y 2
nos va a dar 5 si promediamos 7 con 3
también nos va a dar 5 si promediamos 6
con 4 nos va a dar 5 y obviamente 5
solito su promedio va a ser 5 ahora
imaginemos que te va a hacer esto te va
a marcar estos 8 números que estoy
encerrando acá este
este otro completo es ese
vimos que si promediamos estos números 9
y 18 con 2 7 con 3 6 con 4 nos va a dar
5 si es y le agregamos 5 el promedio va
a seguir siendo 5 así que está la media
de ese es la media de t es verdadera
veamos la opción b después vamos a usar
lo que ya establecimos aquí en para
probar todo lo que necesitamos cuál es
la mediana de t aquí tenemos 8 números
así que debemos promediar los dos
números en medio 4.6 y el promedio de 4
655 es la mediana dt y la mediana de s
pues como ya incluya 5 pues también es
la misma mediana la mediana de s es
igual a la mediana de t también se
cumple la tercera opción el rango de s
es igual al rango de t
recordemos que el rango es la diferencia
entre el número mayor y el número menor
el rango de s es igual al número mayor
que es 9 - el número menor que es 1 por
lo que
8 ahora para sacar el rango de t
el rango de té igual tomamos el número
mayor de té que es 9 - el número menor
que es 1 y también nos va a dar 8 este
se cumple cuarta opción la media de ese
es mayor que la media de té bueno este
sí podría darse imagínense que te sigue
siendo este mismo pero ese en lugar de
tener aquí un 5 yo le pongo un 50
bueno aquí la media ya podría ser
diferente podría ser mayor ésta también
es verdadera y sospecho que esta última
es la que va a ser falsa pero vamos a
ver el rango de ese es menor que el
rango de t bueno ya vimos que es el
rango es la diferencia entre el número
mayor - el número menor pero recordemos
que t es más pequeño y es parte de ese
así que el rango de ese no puede ser más
pequeño que el dt que es un subconjunto
de s
este no es verdadero y el inciso que
tiene esta configuración es el siguiente
problema 209 cuántos enteros positivos
diferentes se pueden formar con los
factores de 441 en esencia tenemos que
factorizar veamos 44 es 8 19 por lo que
debe ser divisible entre 3 hagamos la
división 441 entre 33 por una 34 menos 3
es una 14 4 por 3 12 14 menos 12 221 7
por 3 21 la división exacta y nos queda
147 ok 147 uno más 457 es 12 12 es
divisible también entre 3 bueno vamos a
hacer la división ahora de 147 entre 3
aquí ponemos 4 3 por 4 12 14 menos 12 es
2 bajamos el 7 y un 9 por 3 627 nos
quedó aquí la división exacta termina ok
entonces 49 también es factor vamos a
hacer una factorización prima tenemos
nuestro número original que s 441 de
aquí lo dividimos entre 3 está tres como
factor y salió 147 de ese 147 tenemos
también 3 como factor y de aquí no salió
49 y si yo multiplico 7 por 7 me va a
dar 49 estos son todos los factores de
441 vamos a escribir los resultados aquí
441 es igual a 3 por 3 por 7 por 7
cuantos enteros positivos puedo
construir con 23 y 27 tenemos pues el 3
vamos a escribirlo aquí en 3 solito
tenemos el 7
23 por 3 es igual a 9 tenemos 3 por 7
que es igual a 21 tenemos 7 por 7 que es
igual a 49 tenemos 3 por 7 por 7 que es
igual a 147 tenemos 3 por 3 por 7 que es
igual a 63 y por supuesto tenemos 1 que
siempre va a ser factor de cualquier
número entonces tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
enteros que podemos formar con estos
factores y esta va a ser nuestra opción
de nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo